Apple's 14-inch MacBook Pro has proven
itself to be the perfect balance between
performance and portability especially
with the new M2 Pro and Max chips and
now that it's been six months since its
release I want to talk about how it
stands in the current MacBook lineup now
that we have the 15 inch MacBook Air
[Music]
in this sixth review I want to focus on
five main topics in the context of how
it compares to the 15 inch air and
that'll give you guys my thoughts on if
it's still worth buying now or waiting
for the new M3 Pro and Max version
that's coming sooner than you think
according to recent leaks now getting
into topic number one we have the
discussion of the display which is a bit
of a dilemma because this 14 inch
display is smaller than the one on the
new 15 inch air but it's quite a lot
more expensive when looking at them side
by side yes the 15 inch is quite a bit
bigger surprisingly because it doesn't
sound like that big of a deal but yes it
is bigger and how does it impact the
general multitasking well I did find
that with the older 13 inch displays it
was very hard to multitask and get
multiple web pages on there with the 14
inch it's not that big of a deal it's
just big enough now especially with the
notch at the top that kind of gives us
an edge to edge display it's a little
bit better but definitely a lot better
on the 15 inch display but it's not a
deal breaker what a lot of people forget
about is the actual features of the
displays where the 14 inch MacBook Pro
does have the 120 hertz Pro motion
feature which gives you a very smooth
display experience when browsing the web
using different apps especially gaming
because you can actually get higher FPS
up to 120 which is a big deal so there's
a lot of advantages in terms of that
display feature you also have the xdr
display feature that goes up to 1600
nits for HDR videos movies that you're
watching which is more enjoyable and
also when you're doing productivity work
and editing HDR content you can actually
do this on the 14 inch but not the 15
inch air that's limited to 600 nits and
surprisingly the 14 inch does have
higher resolution so it's a bit more
sharp even while having a smaller
display so all in all in terms of the
actual multitasking experience the 14
inch is just good enough but not as good
as the 15. now with either of them and
especially the 14 inch MacBook Pro the
best way to boost your multitasking
workflow is with the geminos Dual stock
monitor from our sponsor mobile pixels
which is a game changer for multitasking
workflow allowing me to drag and drop
files and clips from the top display
right into my video editing app on the
bottom all while taking screenshots from
my video on my MacBook saving me time
and money and it's all stacked onto this
compact base which saves desk space and
comes with a bunch of extra ports so
check out the geminos dual stack monitor
using the link below but now getting
back to the display discussion the 14
inches currently 1950 on Amazon compared
to 12.50 for the Mac MacBook Air so why
would you pay more for a smaller display
well the biggest reason is the
performance but before I get into that I
want to talk about the portability as
you can see the 14 inch is quite a bit
smaller in terms of the footprint
allowing you to fit it into smaller
backs yes it is actually quite a bit
thicker but the thickness doesn't really
matter that much when you're carrying it
around yes the 15 inch feels very nice
because of how thin it is when you're
using it and when you're holding it but
in terms of impacting the actual
portability it's not a huge deal and
surprisingly even though the 14 inch is
smaller than the air it's actually a
little bit heavier by 0.2 of a pound but
in general it's not that big of a
difference in terms of the actual weight
so they're fairly similar the air just
feels lighter because it's larger and
thinner so in my opinion the 14 inch
definitely takes the win in terms of the
portability a category just because of
that smaller footprint making it squeeze
into smaller bags which is very nice and
now let's get into topic number three
which is performance is the extra
performance with the M2 Pro MacBook Pro
worth the extra price of 700 well first
of all you've got to consider the fact
that the air only comes with the 256 gig
SSD at the base price and the 14 also
has an extra eight gigs of RAM so if you
were to upgrade both of those things on
the 15 inch air that would bring the
price up to basically 1700 so it's no
longer that big of a difference however
the 15 inch air still lets you get in at
that lower base price which is always
nice for those on a budget but getting
back to the actual performance
differences that I've seen over the past
six months the main thing you've got to
understand is that the single core
performance between both of these is
basically the same so common web-based
apps will honestly perform around the
same like for example web-based app
design performance doesn't really change
in apps like figma in terms of both
loading speed and exporting with this
project from 500 designs one of the best
Design Studios based out of La it's
actually the multitasking that matters
with the base 10 core M2 Pro chip being
a whopping 25 faster which is going to
help in a variety of professional apps
like photo editing programming and much
more but honestly after six months I've
realized that if you're not doing this
type of work every day or you're just
not working on big projects all the time
the M2 Chip in the 15-inch air is
probably just fine for a lot of people
and now let's get into topic number four
which is everyday usability and
convenience for example the 14-inch
MacBook Pro has a bunch of extra ports
that make it more useful for day-to-day
life I recently bought a professional
digital camera and that SD card slot on
the side has been amazing now on the 15
inch ear you have to have that dongle
and of course the HDMI port which is now
upgraded I also love that this comes
with better specs like Wi-Fi 6E which is
great the speakers on this thing are
still so much better than the ones on
the new 15-inch air and now let's finish
off with topic number five which is
battery life now I was personally quite
disappointed to hear that the new
15-inch air would have the same rated 18
hours of battery life as the 13 inch air
and the 14 inch MacBook Pro that's 18
hours now one reason is of course the
pro motion Tech on the 14 inch pro that
allows the refresh rate of the screen to
go down to 24 Hertz but then even
further one downside of having the M2
Pro chip in the 14 inch is that it can
use quite a bit more power when Under
full load but overall when you're just
using it for basic and common things
like browse on the web there isn't
really that much of a difference between
these two so with all of that said the
14 inch MacBook Pro still has a great
place in the MacBook lineup and if you
need a Macbook right now and you're
doing things like gaming and
productivity work I would definitely
suggest this over the 15 inch air but if
you're able to wait another year I would
definitely suggest waiting for the M3
Pro chip model of the 14 inch because
Mark German says that is coming before
the end of next year's summer so in the
middle of the year that's very soon that
means we have basically less than a year
so hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did you can subscribe right there
and check out one of those two videos
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
foreign